the Joe Rogan experience Australia is a
mess in that in that sense like wildlife
wise because there's so much so many
things that are invasive this last time
we were there for the first time I
actually went to a sanctuary one of
those places and with Jeremiah and Joel
and we had a blast man there are some
crazy animals down there we held a koala
bear
took a picture with a koala let me tell
you they every I feel like the American
version of that animal seems like so
cute and like soft and light it feels
like a stuffed animal what we think a
koala is and we went we wouldn't take a
picture of this thing this lady handed
me this koala it was like it felt like
it was tiny right same size that I
thought it would be but the thing was
like [ __ ] three bowling balls it's
just so heavy and it's a bear it's a
real bear and a thing and exactly we
call it a koala it's a koala but yet but
the bleep though it should be illegal to
say it without the word bear attached to
it because let me tell you this [ __ ]
thing they have to feed these things
eucalyptus leaves the entire time it's
all of these well what they didn't what
the I what I didn't know is that that's
all it eats and that's all it does like
the second this thing is done with with
one of the eucalyptus leaves they have
to hand it another one because you can
feel its energy change turns its head
and it gets like a [ __ ] little bit of
a look like these things ready to [ __ ]
you up
you have to him just keep feeding this
these are like the drug addicts on an IV
drip that are starting to feel pain the
second they don't have the drip of
course look how much nutrition is a
goddamn eucalyptus leaf they probably
have to eat them you have to stuff
themselves with it
yeah and they're solid as a rock so
think about all that they must you know
oh my god and you know the claws it's
just it's a real bear man which well it
wasn't until I held that koala in which
I realized the true power of an what we
consider an actual bear oh my god
because it's like that thing is this big
right and it felt like that was that
strong and sturdy and there and their
hands and everything you feel everything
it makes
to say it's a ball of muscle would be a
tremendous understatement and honest to
god man I thought we were gonna go take
pictures with these koalas cuz they have
the little girl zookeepers and they seem
super comfortable and they're giggling
and happy and everything but it ended up
being a serious situation I was scared I
was hilarious very scared Jeremiah kept
making fun of me because of how scared I
was I'm like I'm good that she's like
you want to take a group picture with
all of you in the babbling nod that was
enough good for you yeah yeah it's you
know they're right now because of a
gigantic wildfire in Australia they've
become functionally extinct which means
that 80% of their range has been
destroyed by wildfire so you can find
anything on that I think might you see
oh there you guys yeah that's how far
away I am look at my hand my good cause
it's thinking about white [ __ ] Tony
[ __ ] you Tony
I'm ready to bite you bro look oh you
guys are telling each other we can't
tell there's this the final result
Jeremiah and that dude break off
literally laughing about that as it's
happening like ya think I would see if
you pull up the article on them koalas
now functionally extinct in Australia
because I think 80% of their range has
been destroyed and you know you're
talking about the only places where they
can live and breed and there's a giant
population of them koalas are
functionally extinct but they need our
health but what does it say well this is
one scene that see Google koalas are
functionally yesterday I looked it up
and these things stink - by the way I I
I was obsessed with the smell of
eucalyptus I had so there's all these
new articles that say there aren't
extinct okay so you know what it
probably was I probably got caught up in
some scientific click the one that says
they may be as of May so they have been
what rated it but it was really recent
where are these ones coming from Caesar
you're looking at older ones from May
see how everything's from Marin Times
Forbes yeah no no look I'm not saying
you're wrong Jamie what I'm saying is
the older ones when they're saying they
were functionally extinct was from man
which doesn't totally make sense because
we're there that many fires in May about
these fires are real reason bunch now
yeah so most most of them are saying no
koalas aren't functionally extinct I
guess yes is after they were bush fires
it overstated claims
okay yeah so that's what you gotta
wonder about today man any time you read
an art like I didn't even read it right
I just read the ahead the heading that's
what they that's how they're getting you
with everything let's click bait and
it's almost like they have to do that
like if you have a great article but it
doesn't have a catchy headline how much
how many people are gonna it's almost
you have you have to come up with
something that's almost a lie yeah you
have to get their attention you have to
at least give them the little bit that
might they article might not even be
about you just have to get them to click
it's like a Salesman or a sales job or
how often is Australia have fires if
they have one a giant one in May and
they have another giant one now and I
was watching a show some some show from
Australia with some dude who's losing
weight like some fitness show you know
his uh his his wife got him to go on
this show when he's losing all his
weight he has to do all these exercises
and [ __ ] and while they were there they
were worried that they're gonna have to
evacuate because he's giant fires were
coming their way I'm like how often is
Australia on fire hmm and when that
place is on fire that's a huge place
with not that many people right yeah
that's been burned equivalent map of
America that's insane dude that is
insane that's insane we're looking at
most of Manhattan and then a giant chunk
of New York State a giant chunk of
Pennsylvania it looks like New Jersey's
completely engulfed that's nuts
that's a huge patch and all out into the
ocean as well that's the thing like if
you look at it that if you pulled way
back at the entire continent and looked
at that little square it wouldn't look
as big Wow look at that
Pittsburgh to Cleveland yeah it'll go go
way back go go go way small so you can
see
the whole continent so that's how you
got to think of Australia so that's how
Australia looks of it huh hopefully I
get out on this hour hey not much we can
do about all right you ready he's
[ __ ] Buffalo hey wouldn't it be fun
to just get dropped off somewhere like
that with a bunch of just like 30 days
worth of stuff and a backpack to survive
and surely lost stuff when you break
your ankle right and then you're
wondering if you gonna die this way that
could be the future of vacations right
fact check our this year as far as
unprecedented conservative commentators
have pointed out a long history of Russ
fryers suggests there is nothing unusual
about this season experts disagree so
it's even worse this season yeah that's
a big chunk of land
[Applause]